good morning believe nation today's
message is this is your time over to you
Anderson Silva awake mode press the TV
go fight this my life and sometimes
everything's changed because you helped
the good work in bed working and good
Spierings bad experience but I love my
job and I talked to my family and i say
i go back to fight because this is me so
i'm very happy because my family given
the sport and help me for bad because my
sons and my wife say that this is your
time this is your life go going and i'm
very happy this is your time to be a
great entrepreneur this is your time not
to ask the permission from your parents
or your friends or your culture to start
your business this is your time to
believe in yourself and jump on board
and launch your company and invest into
it and believe in yourself because if
you sit around like most people and wait
for that perfect opportunity wait for
that perfect business wait for you to be
perfectly set up it never comes there is
no perfect time the time is now this is
your time if you wait too long you're
going to be held down by the change of
mediocrity you're going to be sitting on
your death bed at 80 years old looking
back in your life and wondering why you
never took your shot this is your time
belief so my question is a for you guys
today is is this your time give me some
emotion in your answer I want to feel it
leave it in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press 0
I reckon more espresso TV I wake up
every morning expresso keep me going
over